bachelor fans this is gonna be a sight
to see too on Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire next because some of your
favorite contestants are hitting the
gameshow I cannot wait for that can you
imagine what kind of wedding a million
bucks would buy for Shaun booth and
Kaitlyn Bristowe mom you might be a
millionaire Kaitlyn and Shawn are
probably gonna be a train wreck
you know what dumpster fire you have to
stop and watch the dumpster fire that
will be Kaitlyn and Shawn
I totally hell's that Chris Blose
because he he makes everybody feel so
relaxed even though he just called us a
dumpster fire right every time I'm
around the guys it's always so dramatic
intense maybe that's because one of the
last times we saw these three together
Shawn was proposing to Kaitlyn on the
season 11 finale of The Bachelorette now
a year and a half later the couple lives
together in Nashville but have yet to
start planning their wedding what about
a wedding with you two I know everyone
wants to know never uh we decided to
announce it on Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire if we get the million
dollars today we'll pick a date you're
going to pick it okay promise yeah all
right other bachelor nation favorites
playing for charity include season fours
Deanna Stagliano JP and Ashley Rosenbaum
from season seven and former bachelor
and current farmer Chris soules but how
would Chris feel about giving villain
bad Chad a try at the game I would
really love the Chad to be out here
playing millionaire I think he would get
to that $500 question not like it and
then choke me out you think this is all
like fun and games this is my life okay
that sounded a little crazy like how
Chris you know who a lot of people would
like to see on The Bachelor Tim Tebow I
mean he is one of the nicest guys ever
to play in the NFL and he told Kevin
that he has been asked a couple of times
I tuned in but check this out would you
ever do the bachelor I will not do the
bachelor I would love to see the 20
women that Tim Tebow gets you can either
select them for television sake I would
bring in a few crazies okay are you
prepared for that no probably not
[Music]
you